Nice!
What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
Today we are doing a special episode with one of our subscribers
He is Stefanos and he's from Greece
Welcome!
Thank you guys it's nice to be here!
I'm a big fan of your channel so I hope we will have a great time today!
I'm sure!
Okay Stefanos, first trick shot.
Around the net and hit the cup
Perfect!
Stefanos is going to show us how Greek people do
the around the net
He has it!
Easy easy! Easy for Stefanos!
Okay let's try with the backhand side
Bullseye!
That was good!
Finally!
That went pretty
well with the around the net!
Yeah, it was good.
Next one is a serve around the cups
And the ball has to land inside the bin.
That should be it...
Yeah, there we go!
A bit more spin and that's it!
Now it goes!
Come! Come to me!
There we go!
Really good!
How long have you been subscribed to Pongfinity?
I think one year for sure.
I've been following your videos
Now it's the time for a between the legs shot.
What do you think?
Sounds good!
Let's go for it!
There we have it!
Nice one!
I'm ready!
Start with the racket here.
And then hit it.
Yeah, like start from there?
Have it here and then hit it
Instead of doing the whole movement.
That was good!
It will hurt!
Perfect!
We have to hit all the cups down from
the table
Let's try!
One more!
It was okay
Nice! Can you hit four in a row?
Better than Pongfinity!
Nice!
Stefanos do you think that you can play behind the back?
That will be very easy!
Yeah? Let's go!
Have your body like this and then you
you hit it like this
So don't turn your head because then you lose the ball
Just a small movement, then it's more safe
Just watch the ball and hit.
There we have it!
I think we are ready to try together!
Yeah, we have it!
That was pretty good!
A friend of mine does this very well
So when she sees this video she will be laughing!
So Stefanos we have been really impressed by your trick shots!
It has been Pongfinity-level!
Really?
That's my honour!
So guys remember to subscribe
and see the previous videos
Exactly!
Until next time!